to go into the first team was obviously
not always the easiest experience but i
think if you say say this to all the the
young players at arsenal that david done
so much you know he went out of his way
to do a lot for us and advice on and off
the pitch
hi i'm bakayo sakai and i'm going to be
answering fan questions for sport bible
if you weren't a footballer what would
you be
if i was a bit taller i think i would
play basketball if i couldn't play
basketball maybe i would be an acton i
like will smith when i was growing up he
was my favorite actor and it's just over
as well i think yeah i'll try and be at
home what's your favorite will smith
film
for me it was always um
always fresh prince of bel-air where i
was like yeah he's really good actor i
think that's one of my favorite tv shows
as well today so i'll say fresh prince
of bella
who was your favorite player growing up
depends of course all time
my favorite player is tyrion rhee when i
was in the academy and i was more close
to watching games and stuff i always
used to love alexis sanchez i think he
was my favorite player the way he played
i just loved him and i still do so
someone like alexis sanchez do you look
at him and think i'd love to have you
know yeah i'll tell you when i was in
the academy i tried to like wear the
same boots as him and stuff like that so
i tried to do a lot of stuff that he did
what do you do to relax
i have time i would i would play games
games like call of duty of course
and yeah just takes my mind off
everything and just enjoy it who's the
best gamer at arsenal the best gamer
arsenal depends what's game we're
speaking about i would say
i don't know overall gamer i have to
give it to myself i'm just gonna go out
there yeah
which player has helped you the most
during your career so far i've had a lot
of help from different players but
i'd say probably the biggest impacts
probably david luiz who's done the most
for me in my career to go into the first
team was obviously not always the
easiest easiest experience but i think
if you say say this to all of the
young players at arsenal that david done
so much you know he went out of his way
to do a lot for us and
advice on and off the pitch so yeah he
was a really a really good guy but
there's been loads of other plays at
austin of course but i'd probably say
david
how would you describe mikhail artita's
management style tactically
he's quite a genius i would say i think
tactically he
he's good at really outsmarting other
teams and he always knows how i was best
to get out in terms of playing at the
back and half best is to press them and
i think as players that really helps you
go into games prepared and knowing what
you have to do to win basically how much
of an influence has he had on you
personally i think since he's come in
he's he's improved me a lot as a player
so a lot of my improvement
i have to thank him for of course
if you could sign one player for arsenal
who would it be
past and present as well
i think it would be thierry on re
there's been a lot of legends at arsenal
you know of course ian wright dennis
burkham but i think
tyrion reed you know what he did that
season specifically the o4 season i
think was special and i think
if he could recreate that for us i think
we would win the league straight away so
i would say thierry yeah what's the
proudest moment of your career so far
the proudest moment of my career so far
has been winning the fa cup for arsenal
how does that measure to play in for
england well i don't know i never really
like to compare club on country
obviously i have goals for my club and
goals for my country as well but
the proudest moment of my career today
would definitely be to
lift the fa cup for for my boyhood team
of course which team do you enjoy
playing against the most i think every
year the game we're looking forward to
of course is the the north london derby
against tottenham i think it's the best
atmosphere and it's the game where
everyone's up for it the most so i'd say
that's the game i look forward to
playing the most how did it feel scoring
it this year
i can't really describe how it felt
scoring
in the northland army i don't know i
can't describe it
do you set yourself goals and assists
targets for the season yeah i do but
i keep them to myself you know i keep
them to myself but i always do that
every single year so yeah did you hit
target last season
um
yeah i hit my target for assists but not
goals last season so
let's see if we can work on that this
year
other than the emirates what's the best
stadium you've played in i thought i'm
gonna say the best thing i've played and
definitely
the emirates if i can't say that i'll
have to say um
barcelona stadium i think it's called
the
new camp if you and harry maguire had a
unicorn race who would win
i think i would win a unicorn race out
of me and harry maguire i think i would
win yeah who is the toughest opponent
you've faced
kyle walker
i think that's pretty self-explanatory
who would you say are the top secrets
now if if lester are in there who's
who's dropped out well liverpool are in
there united are in there city are in
there chelsea are in there
tottenham and leicester in the last few
years i would say arsenal fans will
probably like caught some stat now that
you know i mean because i think i ate
them anyway
it's like they drain me start winning i